CATASTROPHIC.
AND THAT IS THE ANGLE.
JOINING US NOW, THREE MEN WHO
KNOW THIS FLORIDA ISSUE BETTER
THAN PRETTY MUCH MOST EVERYONE
IN THE COUNTRY, BARRY RICHARD IS
CURRENTLY ANDREW GILLUM'S
ATTORNEY, ALSO REPRESENTED
GEORGE W. BUSH IN THE 2000
FLORIDA RECOUNT PAIRED MATILDA
GRANDY WAS ALSO PART OF GOD BUSH
LEGAL TEAM, AND JUST A
CLOCK WAS THE ATTORNEY FOR
SECOND OF STATE
CATHERINE HERRIDGE THAT VERY
SAME RECOUNT, REPRESENTING HER
AGAINST ALL OF THESE LEGAL
CHALLENGES.
JOSEPH, I WANT TO START WITH YOU
TONIGHT.
YOU THINK IT IS WISE FOR
GOVERNOR SCOTT TO MOVE ON THE
OFFENSIVE, AS I DO, AGAINST
BROWARD AND PALM BEACH COUNTIES,
OR IS THAT PREMATURE?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK IT IS
PREMATURE.
YOU HAVE TO SORT OF STAY AHEAD
OF THE FLOW, WHAT IS GOING ON, I
THINK ALL OF THE DASH I WAS NOT
AWARE OF THE LAWSUIT UNTIL I
DROVE OVER HERE TONIGHT, BUT
WHAT HE WANTS TO DO IS JUST MAKE
SURE THERE IS JUDICIAL
SUPERVISION OF WHAT IS GOING ON,
THINGS DON'T HAPPEN THAT OUGHT
NOT HAPPEN.
>> Laura: BARRY, I WANT TO GO
TO YOU, YOU ARE REPRESENTING
ANDREW GILLUM.
HE DID CONCEDE THE OTHER NIGHT,
BUT AS HE SAID EARLIER TONIGHT,
I HEARD YOU, THAT IS NOT A
CONTRACT.
HE THOUGHT THE MOMENT WARRANTED
A CONCESSION.
BUT YOUR CLIENT AND YOU SAY YOU
ARE WATCHING THINGS VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE VOTE COUNT.
LAST I CHECKED, I THINK IT WAS
ABOUT 40,000 OR SO VOTES
SEPARATING GILLUM, OF COURSE,
AND RON DeSANTIS.
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING AT TONIGHT?
>> THERE IS A VAST DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN 2000 AND NOW.
IN 2000, THE RECOUNT WAS
PRECIPITATED BY THE CANDIDATES
WHO HAD TO REQUEST THEM AND GOT
TO SELECT WHICH COUNTIES THEY
WERE ENTERED THE LEGISLATOR AS A
RESULT OF 2000 HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
CHANGED FLORIDA STATUTES.
THE CANDIDATES REALLY HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH IT NOW, IF
THE MARGIN BETWEEN THE
CANDIDATES IS LESS THAN
0.5 PERCENT, IT IS AN AUTOMATIC
SO-CALLED MACHINE RECOUNT, WHERE
THEY BALLOTS ARE SENT THROUGH
THE MACHINES AGAIN.
IF IT IS LESS THAN 0.25 PERCENT,
THEN THERE IS AN AUTOMATIC,
STATEWIDE, MANUAL RECOUNT.
AS FAR AS IT MR. GILLUM IS
CONCERNED, HE IS JUST WAITING
FOR THE SYSTEM TO PLAY ITSELF OT
FOR THE SYSTEM TO PLAY ITSELF O.
THAT IS PART OF THE ELECTORAL
PROCESS, IT IS PART OF THE VOTE
COUNTING, AND HE WILL ACCEPT THE
RESULTS.
>> Laura: MIGUEL, I WANT TO GO
TO YOU.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE WATCHING
ACROSS THE COUNTRY FIND IT VERY
ODD, THIS WHOLE PROCESS OF THE
VOTE COUNT EXPENDING SO MANY
DAYS.
EXPLAIN TO THE VIEWERS WHY THAT
IS, WITH PROVISIONAL BALLOTS,
WHAT THOSE ARE, AND MOVING INTO
ABSENTEE, MILITARY COUNT, WHICH
I UNDERSTAND AND FLORIDA HAVE
NOT BEEN COUNTED YET.
>> PROVISIONAL AND ABSENTEE --
MILITARY ABSENTEES -- ARE ONE
ISSUE, BUT WHAT WE CAN'T
UNDERSTAND IS WHY IS IT THAT
MAIL IN BALLOTS AND EARLY VOTES
ARE STILL BEING COUNTED AND HAVE
NOT YET BEEN PROPERLY RECORDED?
ACCORDING TO OUR LAWS, THOSE
VOTES ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
UPLOADED THE DAY BEFORE ELECTION
SO THEY CAN BE REPORTED HALF AN
HOUR AFTER THE VOTES CLOSE FOR
THE NEXT DAY.
SO WE UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN PALM BEACH AND
BROWARD, IT IS THE SAME TWO
COUNTIES THAT CAN'T SEEM TO GET
IT RIGHT OUT OF OUR 67 COUNTIES
IN THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE
CONCERN -- I WANT TO GO BACK TO
YOU, JOSEPH, ABOUT BRENDA
SNIPES?
IN BROWARD I'M IN THE CONCERN
THAT MARCO RUBIO -- HE WAS ON
ANOTHER NETWORK -- NO, HE WAS ON
OUR NETWORK, EARLIER TONIGHT,
AND HE BASICALLY LAID WASTE TO
WHAT HAPPENS IN BROWARD COUNTY.
THE PRESIDENT WEEDED OUT ABOUT
THIS ALSO TONIGHT, WHICH WE WILL
PUT UP ON THE SCREEN, WE PUT IT
UP ON THESE GREEN AND I WILL
GO BACK TO YOU, JOSEPH.
THIS IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
TONIGHT.
HE SAID, "LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
LOOKING INTO ANOTHER BIG
CORRUPTION SCANDAL HAVING TO DO
WITH ELECTION PROUD IN BROWARD
AND PALM BEACH, FLORIDA.
FLORIDA VOTED FOR RICK SCOTT."
YOUR COMMENT TONIGHT, JOSEPH.
>> AS IT BARRY SAID, OUR
LEGISLATOR THOUGHT THEY
ADDRESSED PROBLEMS FOR THIS
HAPPENING.
IT IS EMBARRASSING FOR THE STATE
THAT THIS KIND OF THING GOES ON.
IN MY HOME COUNTY, WE DON'T HAVE
THIS KIND OF THING HAPPENING
HERE.
BECAUSE IT MISSED SNIPES
APPARENTLY HAS OF THIS CLOUD
HANGING OVER HER HEAD, IF THERE
IS INDEED A BALLOTS THAT NOW
SHOWING UP, THEY SHOULDN'T BE.
AT THE ONLY POLICY SHOULD BE
WAITING FOR AT THIS POINT IN
TIME OF THE MILITARY BALLOTS
FROM WHICH I UNDERSTAND HAVE
UNTIL NOVEMBER 16TH, SO I THINK
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
TAKE WHATEVER STEPS ARE
NECESSARY WITH THE JUDICIARY TO
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF THE
SYSTEM SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
THESE PROBLEMS.
I THINK BARRY WILL AGREE THAT
ONE OF THE REASONS WE STILL HAVE
THIS IS WE DON'T HAVE STATEWIDE
CONTROLS OVER BALLOTING, IT IS
DONE ON A COUNTY BY COUNTY
BASIS, AND THAT IS WHY YOU CAN
HAVE THESE OUTLIERS.
>> Laura: GOT IT.
SO BARRY, I DIDN'T PRACTICE
ELECTION LAW, BUT I REMEMBER
BEING IN MIAMI BEACH DURING THE
RECOUNT -- I THINK I REMEMBER
SEEING YOU GUYS DOWN THERE AT
THE TIME.
THIS IS WHAT RICK SCOTT SAID,
JUST A SHORT WHILE AGO,
REFERRING TO MARC ELIAS IN
TALLAHASSEE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I WILL NOT SIT IDLY BY WHILE
UNETHICAL LIBERALS TRYING TO
STEAL THE SELECTION FROM THE
GREAT PEOPLE OF FLORIDA.
HILLARY CLINTON'S LAWYERS FROM
D.C., AND THE FIRST THING HE DID
D.C., AND THE FIRST THING HE DIW
D.C., AND THE FIRST THING HE DIS
D.C., AND THE FIRST THING HE DIT
D.C., AND THE FIRST THING HE DIL
D.C., AND THE FIRST THING HE DIR
D.C., AND THE FIRST THING HE DIP
D.C., AND THE FIRST THING HE DIE
D.C., AND THE FIRST THING HE DIS
D.C., AND THE FIRST THING HE DIH
D.C., AND THE FIRST THING HE DIE
IS HERE TO WIN THE ELECTION.
NOW HE IS HERE TO TRYING TO
STEAL THE ELECTION AND TO THWART
LEAVE WILL OF THE VOTERS OF
FLORIDA.
>> Laura: YOUR REACTION, TOUGH
WORDS FROM RICK SCOTT TONIGHT.
HE IS CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO SIT
BACK IN WHAT HE BELIEVES IS AN
ELECTION STOLEN FOR HIM AT THE
HANDS OF MISS SNIPES.
>> I HAVE NO REACTION IN THE
FIRST PLACE, I AM NOT INVOLVED
IN THAT RACE.
IN THE SECOND PLACE, IT IS NOT
MY PURPOSE TO BECOME INVOLVED IN
THE POLITICAL DEBATE, I AM JUST
THE LAWYER REPRESENTING A CLIENT
ILLEGALLY, AND THOSE THINGS ARE
BEYOND MY SPIRIT        SPHERE F
REPRESENTATION.
>> Laura: THE OLD SAYING, I'M
NOT TALKING ABOUT IT, I RESPECT
THAT.
GOOD FOR YOU, BARRY.
>> NOW, THAT IS NOT WHAT I DO.
I'M A LAWYER, I REPRESENT A
CLIENT.
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS.
I >> Laura: I GOT IT.
I DIDN'T SOUND OR OTHERWISE.
I APPRECIATE IT.
MY GAL COME I WANT GO TO YOU ON
THIS.
OBVIOUSLY, WE WANT TO PROTECT
THE INTEGRITY OF THE BOAT.
I AGREE WITH STACEY ABRAMS AND
EVERYONE ELSE WHO HAS HAD EVERY
VOTE SHOULD COUNT.
IF YOU VOTED, ELIGIBLE TO VOTE,
YOUR VOTE SHOULD COUNT.
I THINK WHAT PEOPLE WATCH THIS,
AND THEY -- HOW IS THIS IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA THAT
THIS KIND OF STUFF SEEMS TO DRAG
ON QWEST MY PEOPLE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THIS DRAGGING ON ANOTHER
FEW WEEKS IN FLORIDA.
AND I THINK THAT IS WHAT EATS
AWAY AT PEOPLE, BOTH ON
DEMOCRATS, REPUBLICANS, PEOPLE
IN THE MIDDLE.
>> LAURA, I CAN'T AGREE MORE.
I LOST MY FIRST ELECTION TO THE
FLORIDA HEALTH        HOUSE OF R
FLORIDA HEALTH        HOUSE OF P
FLORIDA HEALTH        HOUSE OF E
FLORIDA HEALTH        HOUSE OF T
FLORIDA HEALTH        HOUSE OF V
FLORIDA HEALTH        HOUSE OF S
BY ONE VOTE IN 1998, SO I AM
VERY KEEN ON THE FACT THAT EVERY
VOTE NEEDS TO BE COUNTED AND THE
ELECTION NEEDS TO BE TABULATED
FAIRLY.
WHAT CONCERNS US ON THIS POINT
IS THE REGULARITY THAT THEY ARE
OCCURRING, WHEN WE CAN'T GIVE
THE BALLOTS -- FOR EXAMPLE, THE
BALLOTS AND DAMAGED, BEING
DUPLICATED, WHICH IS REQUIRED
BY LAW, IN THE PRESENCE OF
WITNESSES, AND WE ARE DENIED
ACCESS TO THAT PROCESS, WE START
HEARING THAT IN
PALM BEACH COUNTY, THERE ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE THEY ARE
ACTUALLY TAKING STEPS THAT ARE
OUTSIDE OF THE PUBLIC DOMAIN,
THAT THEY ARE DIVINING VOTER
INTENT, WHEN THAT IS THE
EXCLUSIVE PROVIDENCE OF THE
CANVASSING BOARD, AND PUTTING
THOSE AS RECORDED VOTES INSTEAD
OF BRINGING THEM TO THE
CANVASSING BOARD FOR THEIR
DETERMINATION OF PUBLIC PROCESS,
WE SHOULD ALL BE VERY CONCERNED.
>> Laura: THEY HAVE TO BE
VERIFIED BY THE PROPER CHANNELS,
NOT JUST A DEFINED -- ATTENTION
DIVINE.
BY THE WAY, GILLUM'S CAMPAIGN
PUT OUT A TWEET, THE GILLAM
CAMPAIGN IS LOOKING FOR
VOLUNTEERS TO HELP CURE
LEFTOVER BALLOTS.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN, BARRY,
SINCE YOU WILL TALK ABOUT YOUR
CLIENT?
PROCURE LEFTOVER BALLOTS, WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN, BARRY?
>> PROCURE LEFTOVER BALLOTS?
>> Laura: THAT IS WHAT YOUR
CAMPAIGN SENT OUT, WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
>> Laura: YOU REPRESENT
SOMEONE, YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
THAT MEANS.
OKAY.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT MEANS
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
REFERENCE WAS TO COME IT IS NOT
SOMETHING I AM INVOLVED IN PIT
ARE NOT TRYING BE DIFFICULT FOR
YOU, BUT WHAT I WAS ASKED TO
COME ON THE SHOW, IT WAS TO
ADDRESS THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THE 2000 CAMPAIGN --
>> Laura: WE GOT IT, THAT IS
THE POINT YOU MADE EARLIER.
>> YOU ARE ASKING ME QUESTIONS
THAT ARE BEYOND --
>> Laura: I'M SORRY, I DIDN'T
KNOW YOU WERE SO SENSITIVE
ABOUT --
>> I'M NOT SENSITIVE.
LISTEN, I'M NOT A POLITICAL
SPOKESMAN.
I'M A LAWYER WHO REPRESENTS
CLIENTS.
WANT TO ASK ME ABOUT THAT, I'M
HAPPY TO RESPOND.
>> Laura: THIS IS YOUR CLIENT,
I IMAGINE, TALKING ABOUT --
>> YOU ASKED ME WHAT A STATEMENT